principles for success an ultra
mini-series adventure in 30 minutes and
in eight episodes episode 8 struggle
well so far I described how I learned to
confront my own realities my problems my
mistakes and weaknesses and how I
surrounded myself with others who could
do things better than I could this was
the most effective way I discovered from
making great decisions this is not the
normal way of being but through this
approach I became very successful and
being successful enabled me to meet
extraordinarily successful people and
see how they think I've discovered that
their journeys were similar to mine you
might not know it but they all struggle
and they all have weaknesses that they
all get around by working with people
who see risks and opportunities that
they would miss over time I learned that
by nature most people's greatest
strengths are also connected to their
most significant weaknesses and striving
hard for big things is bound to lead you
to painful Falls it's just part of the
process such setbacks will test you they
sort people some think hard about what
caused their setbacks learn lessons and
continue progressing toward their goals
while others decide that this game is
not for them and get off the field I've
come to realize that success is not a
matter of attaining one's goals I found
that when I reached each new higher
level of success I really remain
satisfied the things we are striving for
are just the bait struggling to get them
forces us to evolve and it is this
struggle toward personal evolution with
others that is the reward I no longer
wanted to get across the jungle but
instead wanted to find greater and
greater challenges to go after
surrounded by great people working
together on a shared journey eventually
the success of the mission and the
well-being of the people alongside me
came more important than my own success
I also started to see beyond myself and
wanted others to be successful when I'm
no longer here I realize that if I fail
to do that I will be a failure I
struggle with this now we all struggle
with different things at different times
until we either choose to give up or
until we die and become part of the
larger evolutionary story this is how
all machines work and are recycled
through time when a machine breaks down
its parts go back into the system to
become parts of new machines that also
evolves through time sometimes this
makes us sad because we've become very
attached to our machines but if you look
at it from the higher level it's really
beautiful to observe how the machine of
evolution works now you must decide for
yourself how you will evolve forget
about where these principles came from
just assess whether or not they are
useful to you and evolve them to suit
your own needs as with all of life's
decisions what you do with them is
ultimately up to you my only hope for
you is that you have the courage to
struggle and evolve well to make your
life as great as it can be
thank you and goodbye
[Music]
you